[Music]
so hi everyone thanks for coming to my
talk it's great to speak at sort of a
homecoming event like this again my name
is Vinson I've been organizing the pilot
for awhile and I would love to talk to
you about why I think is one of the
biggest problems out there because I
think as a data scientist community and
as sort of if I look at what people
doing with data and I must say like this
is not necessarily based on stuff I see
actual human beings do it's also stuff
that I read of and like hacker news and
stuff but I think we are sometimes in a
profession of solving the wrong problem
and there's a couple of two stories and
like I'll show you share some theory
theory of failures and stuff but before
I sort of explain what I'm gonna talk
about during the entire talk I kind of
want to tell you a true story and as a
crowd I would love to remind you that
this is a true story this actually
happened it is the first failure I've
ever experienced using data I must
stress it actually happened it's also
something I learn a lot from but it is
also super embarrassing because it is
the story of the first a plus it's also
the only a plus that I've ever gotten in
college I guess imagine the stories
kinda like there's like some of you
probably had like an educational
background where you also have this
first-year class in statistics very
typically what the professor's really
like you to do is you know you have your
first year statistics you know what a
regression is then the teacher says go
out there and find yourself a real-world
data set and apply statistics to it and
there were some students who were doing
like I remember a friend of mine doing
like research on you know the population
size of a country and how many Olympic
medals you might win etc but as it was
while I was doing this gig about what
was doing statistics I had a game like a
job at a bar in a local theatre and the
theater just celebrated its 12th year
anniversary and they kinda had a problem
because they were thinking about maybe
expanding but I didn't really know for
sure so I asked for their data but
they're like growth rates and stuff and
they happily gave to me and then
hopefully I could apply statistics and
if I could apply statistics I would both
impress my boss who might give me a
raise and I might get an A from the
professor so the chart I'm about to show
you was made in like 2007 so it was made
with illustrator I had to actually
manually draw every single rectangle
like this so thank you to all the
matplotlib committers that we don't have
to do it anymore
but the graph that you're looking at is
sort of the growth rate so like a year
one
like a lot of growth compared to the
year before what we're doing is we're
checking how many people were in a room
the year before and how many people in
the room now like in a theater room so
to say and you know in the beginning you
see the Grove is like pretty high and
then after that the Groves kind of low
and then you know 12 data points so I
did what my professor asked me I put the
linear regression line through this and
it turned out to be significant right
that's great so even if you have 12
points of data statistically you can
sort of point out that something might
be significant and this gave me
statistical evidence to point out that
the theater should not expand because
clearly the growth have been stagnated
and the teacher loved it because the
teacher actually said yo you actually
went out there you got like a business
case you solved it within a couple of
weeks
ten out of ten so you know the best the
futures looking great cuz I'm a young
kid and I can do you know data science
I'm gonna be a enterprise person wear a
suit and make money and all that then
two years like two days later I was at
the same bar at the same theater and you
know you know these evenings were behind
the bar and like the house is like super
path like this everyone's sweating
because it's so packed it was one of
these nights and then the week after I
had another one these nights where the
house was like super packed and like
people were sweating and stuff so then I
started thinking you know technically
you cannot sell more tickets if every
chair and a theater is taken so the
growth might have stagnated it's simply
because there were no more seats to sell
and if you then put a model through the
thing that says yeah the growth has
stopped you are measuring the wrong
thing and you were sort of solving the
wrong problem and this definitely
happened my boss was super happy with
the result my statistics professor was
super happy to result but this was one
of those moments where I was so focused
on the method that I completely
neglected the fact that I was chasing a
fancy task and as always at these sort
of moments where you look yourself in
the mirror and you say crap I solved the
wrong problem and it's not just me I
think a lot of people a lot of times
they're having this problem over and
over and over again you know like
solving problems is hard I'm not
suggesting that solving problems is
always super easy but lately I've
noticed that exactly what happened to me
when I was like in college I see that
happens to like a bunch of people I've
noticed that algorithms are sort of
starting to distract us from over
actually supposed to do
and like there's a lot of height like
hacker news and whatnot like that the
algorithm might save us right there's a
lot of hyper and deep learning and all
these things but in this talk I kind of
hope to convince you that it's all the
stuff around the algorithm that was
actually the solution that maybe the
algorithm itself is not really a special
citizen or anything like that but if we
are able to convince ourselves of this
that maybe we're gonna be much better at
making solutions and I'll share a few
stories one story about a recommender
one story about rephrasing and world
hunger one story about a kaggle hack
which is the funniest thing and a story
about a time series task so I hope we're
excited about that
I'm assuming that at least a lot of you
are Dutch and if you're Dutch you've
probably noticed this website for those
of you that are not familiar with this
website basically this is the Dutch BBC
and for those of you does not use to
Dutch BBC this is online television it's
like Netflix and if you're not familiar
to Netflix welcome to my idea but so the
idea is when you pause the video or when
you're like at the end of the video
there's this prompts it sort of says hey
you're watching this content maybe you
like to watch this other content as well
and the idea here is of course that you
know if you see something you might like
other people might have also seen stuff
that you might like which another where
of it so the organizations for the came
up to us and said hey would you like to
maybe you know do some recommender stuff
maybe do something with algorithms and
the way I kind of work that I'll be
paraphrasing a little bit like when I
joined this project there were like two
months of data like one of our engineers
started collecting data making some
stacks and stuff and it's not like they
didn't have anything at the moment like
their editorial department had like a
rule-based system that was actually not
the worst idea like if you watch
something from a certain broadcaster
maybe recommend something that's popular
from the same broadcaster like in that
sort of realm they kind of already have
something and when we started talking to
them they were sort of thinking like
yeah like if you could cost 25 percent
clicks that would be kind of a nice goal
if you get like 25 percent clicks extra
then your recommender is sort of doing
better and I've been talking with them
and they were really really like they
really understood the product in this
sense we quickly came to the conclusion
that clicks is not the thing we're
interested in if you can optimize for
clicks what you're gonna do then is like
click baiting instead what we said was
we like it if people click we like it
even more if people watch the content
after the click so it's really cool if
you're gonna watch the next episode of
the show but you're not gonna watch it
like the click is okay we want you to
watch it afterwards and
as we were sort of discussing this there
were people in my filter bubble around
me that we're suggesting like oh you got
to do recommender you should totally
check out this thing called deep
learning and what I kind of want to
mention is like a lot of people at this
point in time say oh there's so many
algorithms here's a paper here's a paper
you should totally do deep learning and
what I just want to mention that's
hopefully the obvious thing the first
thing you do is not consider deep
learning the first thing you do is you
draw something up like this because
you're trying to understand the problem
it better so what we had was like a part
where we had like the video player and
those sort of the user interface and out
of that came like okay this user if
we're gonna check if a recommender is
better we also need have some sort of
way to do a be testing like if I cannot
prove that my algorithm is better than
your algorithm there's no way to sort of
put you an A in the B group and then if
I think about it after that happens
probably I'm not going to be able to
calculate these things on the fly
because it might be a heavy calculation
so I'm probably gonna be needing a
database and the database is kind of
like a caching mechanism such as I can
say okay this item maps to all of these
items and I should definitely calculate
that beforehand and if I have a database
I need something of a cron job or
airflow where the new data comes in and
then there's like an algorithm that I
can apply that put yourself into this
database but even after that taking
about the problem again I cannot my
probably cannot recommend all the
material all the time so as great as die
hard is as a movie to some people I
should never recommend that after Sesame
Street and I don't know if it's like
normal for me to expect that the
algorithm will always automatically pick
this up there's a lot of artificial
stupidity that could happen there so I
do need some sort of checking mechanism
just to be sure that nothing bad will
happen and you know this is one of the
first things you typically do you draw a
thing like this but one thing I want to
point out the algorithm is like a small
cog in this entire system it's all the
stuff around the algorithm that actually
brings the solution to the table and
will make everything work this algorithm
is like small beans compared to the rest
of it
and I do hope it's sort of obvious that
like 90% of the effort in sort of
engineering and all that it's not the
algorithm it's all the other stuff
so if the imagine the deep learning
people around me they were sort of like
okay that sort of makes sense let's
let's build all of that first so yes
imagine then the project went on and
again I'm paraphrasing but let's imagine
that we built everything below the
algorithm
stuff here and then the deep learning
people sort of come in the office again
they say oh dude leave learning let me
use tensorflow and then there will be a
very good time to say no because the
thing you probably want to do first
because if you're gonna use an a/b
testing system and you want that a be
testing system is sort of be reliable
for the next five years the first thing
you probably wanna do is test this a be
testing system because it's very like it
happens sometimes that this a/b testing
system is not purely random but there's
some sort of bias that certain people
from certain areas of the Netherlands
maybe are overpopulated in the a group
as opposed in the B group and I would
really really hate it if five years from
now I discover that the a/b testing
system is broken so there's nothing
wrong with running an a a test it's like
one of those things where if you just do
that your solution is already a bit more
reliable so again you've sinned imagined
there's some deep learning people that
sort of go okay that's also reasonable I
guess sure but then again there were
some some thoughts like okay once you do
that can you then do deep learning and
then again we sort of said no because
there's some other stuff you can do
that's also better for the solution
which you can also do if you want to
understand the system how about we just
have an algorithm B there's nothing more
than just random stuff so I just give
you a random episode if you do that you
know that that's obviously not the best
algorithm but the cool thing is you do
measure how many people will click
anyway and if I want to compare my
algorithm to like people who click
anyway that margin is something that's
very interesting suppose that your
algorithm is like 2.2 percent people
that click and stuff but randomness will
have two percent of people click as well
then you get a pretty good proxy that
you probably do not understand the
problem and measuring that I think is a
very good thing but it's one of those
steps that people sort of forget about
because they focus on the algorithm and
even after you do this before you do
deep learning there's another thing you
can sort of do because if you think
about bias and people clicking anyway
what you can also even do is like test
the order of things in here right so you
might even say something in the order of
well this algorithm things that one item
one is the best item well if people are
going to click the first item anyway how
about we put the best item of slot
number three maybe that way more people
will click in total because you can
convince more people to sort of click
the
better thing and again this is one of
those moments where it's a very good
thing to just test and you can totally
do this before you've been thinking
about the algorithm because it helps you
understand the problem a whole lot
better so if the imagine like the team I
was in we were doing stuff like this we
were really really fundamentally just
trying to figure out you know is this
sort of the problem are we sort of
getting a system is just going to work
and also while doing this we were
continually testing to a be splitting
stuff the database scaling and the
checking mechanism these are all things
that we were really able to test they
were working properly so by this time
the deep learning people were getting
kind of antsy right so there's this
whole ease algorithm that people who are
sort of waiting all this time for us to
sort of really push the big algorithm is
supposed to go out and I had kind of had
to disappoint a lot of them because when
we were sort of thinking about it we at
some point said you know instead of deep
learning how about we just recommend the
next episode which made the deep
learning advocates kind of go oh right
and again this I'm definitely
paraphrasing here it's not in the case
that they were like actually deep
learning people knocking the door and
demanding anything like that that's not
how it happened but I do notice a lot of
the times that there's these people who
sort of dream about a solution but not
about the problem and that is a problem
because if you think about it just to
emphasize a few of these hype cycles I
don't think the real issue in 2016 was
that we weren't using Apache spark I
still do not think that the problem in
2018 was that we were not using deep
learning I also do not think that this
year the problems going to be they were
not using out of ml even though hacker
news is suggesting you should all use it
now I think the problem is probably more
in the sense that as a data scientist
you typically don't talk to your end
users and maybe you don't regularly
drink coffee with the working people who
are supposed to be using your app I also
think because we're probably trained to
really really think about a sort of
quantitative way about our algorithms
and of other systems that maybe we
forget about the qualitative level about
our system and the reason why I think
that that is so sort of important that
we don't lose I of that is because by
doing all these experiments and by sort
of trying to understand the system I was
actually able to design a really really
good algorithm here and to explain the
thought there like imagine if you will
that like I have a couple of series I've
Series A F Series B I've got Series C
and let's suppose that I know that you
just watched series a and the overlap of
people that watch Series C and the
people that watched series B that's
equal has 50 people who watch both shows
so to say the only real difference is
that this show is more popular than that
show well if that's the case for this
platform I think it's a much much better
idea to recommend C because if you think
about it be for example an extreme case
could be the news and everyone could be
watching the news right that's something
as you will watch independent of our
recommendations it makes no sense to
recommend something that you're going to
be watching anyway and with this
philosophy in mind it's it was
relatively easy to just come up with
some sort of formula and the easy
version is just this is the overlap that
you saw in the chart before and this is
sort of the entire circle that we had in
a Venn diagram before this is the stuff
that I do like this is the stuff that I
don't like if I just calculate this
between all the series I and J I have a
pretty good score function I'm basically
I have in my mind what I would like to
see in my algorithm and by just defining
the score function like this I also have
the algorithm there's some like tons of
benefits about this algorithm because
it's just counting right one of the
other cool things like sending you from
I to J is not equal to sending you from
J die but this simple formula like a
variant of this is still alive I think
at that client and I've used this
algorithm a bunch and a bunch of times
and it turns out it works quite well if
your interest is that you want to cause
a lot of serendipity by thinking about
the problem you realize this is a
formula for serendipity it's a way to
describe that and I believe the
algorithms life today when we launched
it it caused some number X % more on the
platform like instantly over the weekend
we just saw like skew going up and we
were also able to prove that we weren't
doing clickbait and this is I think the
coolest chart that I've ever made in my
career I do have to explain a little bit
but imagine if you will that this was
the chart for there for what people
click so if this is very high then in
2016 if you click a recommendation that
comes from the business rule engine most
of the stuff you will be clicking is
from 2016
so this chart is sort of saying is if
you were getting your recommendations
from the biz
rulz odds are that the content you're
watching is probably from the most
recent year but if you were watching us
from like my formula with like the thing
I came up with it was actually kind of
normal that people would not just click
but watch content from like four years
ago
so we were able to really prove that
this algorithm wasn't just giving people
that what they wanted to click on but we
were actively diversifying sort of all
the content they were having and if
you're like a person who has lots of
content but you this is great because
this is all content you're not paying
for anymore and if you can still use
we'll find ways to get people interested
in that content that's a win-win because
it's content you don't have to pay for
and for me at least some of the lessons
here was like because I was able to
qualitatively think about this problem
you know if you have a good heuristic to
for loops in an if statement can totally
whooping neural network SAS that's it's
kind of easy to do you just have to
understand the problem very well and
this mental thing of taking a step back
and wondering like what's the actual
problem that's a very sort of nice way
to get there and I don't think there's
any shame and trying to understand the
problem because if you do a lot of these
a B test to try to understand your users
that is a very good progress towards a
good solution and blindly following a
book or a blog would probably not have
given me this approach and just to
mention this is this algorithm was
really sweet because if you look at the
entire system there's all sorts of parts
that we can just go ahead and replace so
if the world changes it's fairly easy
probably an assistant like this to sort
of make amends and make sure that you're
able to change it's the world changes
yeah and again I wouldn't simply not
have gotten here if I would have
believed the true like deep learning
gospel or anything like that they're
just taking a step back and wondering
what am I actually doing next episode
and the heuristic like this it really
goes a long way and this is like one
situation where I was very happy and
able to sort of you know avoid solving
the wrong problem I think but there's
other situations as well and to sort of
exemplify how you might be able to solve
a problem by rephrasing it what I will
first do is give like a mathematical
introduction to what I mean by that and
then I will tell you a story about how
the world food organization as has been
told by me I was able to save a bunch of
lives
who here watch it like I've ever heard
of like 99% of visible the podcast you
raise your hand if you've seen like a
couple of you okay it's like an amazing
podcast and if you're interested in
having like very odd math questions to
solve listen to this podcast ago it's
about design and this is one episode
where there was a competition where if
you would live on the Billboard for as
long as possible you might be able to
win a house and it was like I think in
the 60s when there was a deep regret
recession in the United States and all
these candidates who got into this
competition
some of them wrote 10,000 letters to the
radio station in order to you know get
into this competition so that's a fun
math problem because what you want to do
is you want to maybe decide the optimal
number of letters to sent to the contest
and you'll lose if they open two of your
envelopes but you'll win if they open
only one so you want to send as many
envelopes as possible such that the odds
of opening one of them is very high but
not too much such as the odds of opening
two envelopes is higher and this is a
fun little math probably this is what I
do when I'm on the bus and if you know
this is listening to the podcast you
kind of go right there's like a couple
of free variables there's like the
number of contestants who will be picked
in total there's a number of letters
that sort of I send in there's a number
of letters that other people send in and
sort of the math equation like if you
only pick one contestant the odds of
being selected is just s over a plus s s
is the number of letters again that I
send in the math is not super important
but if only one person is picked it had
you just want to send as many letters as
possible and then if two people get
picked okay it's sort of the same thing
except you can be either the first
person who gets picked or you can be the
second person who gets picked and you
have to sort of follow the math but it
kind of gets tricky here because it's
not just s on top of the equation here
but it's also an S below the equation
here so it's a bit more of a complicated
formula if you want to do this for being
picked thrice I mean the beginning of
the math again is easy because you could
say okay you're either the first person
who gets elected the second person who
gets elected or the third one first
second third
but if then if you combine that into
like one formula it gets kind of tricky
because you want to optimize for s and s
is above the division as well as below
so differentiating this is kind of
tricky
and there's a very cool tool called
senpai you can just throw it in there
and usually it solves everything
but even simple had a problem because
differentiating basically made the
equation longer and trying to solve this
for zero my computer just gave up at
some point so this is actually kind of a
very tricky math problem because you
have to the French data free variable is
both above the divider is below but but
here's the funny thing if you just take
this one small step to rephrase one
thing what I could do is I could say how
about I take a plus s and that's equal
to T and I'll have that be the constant
and s still be the free variable but I
can rephrase this equation into this one
and again T is now a constant and this
is a polynomial isn't super easy to
solve this is like not even a calculus
exam my calculus exam questions are way
harder than this typically so then you
have a closed form solution and it's
great and the only way that you would
have gotten here is you would have the
insight that your math equation needed
to be rephrased that was sort of the
thing the trick that made this a lot
easier than it had to be is it as easy
as it should be and this is like a very
small mental step right just rephrase
like one equation and that's it but I've
noticed at the machine learning there's
a lot of opportunities where a similar
thing sort of happens it's very hard to
recognize but rephrasing is actually a
very awesome tool to solve a real-world
problem and again I'm about to tell you
a problem I heard the second hand I was
at the different conference for
operations research people so I wasn't
involved in any of this research but I
think the drive at the point that I'm
baking will derive everything home so if
to imagine that if you're the world food
organization you tried it like there's a
lot of villages let's say that are in
shortening the food so what you can do
as a village you can sort of say hey I
need red beans and beef and then there
are some volunteers at the world food
organization who are into like
logistical algorithms like the
operations Research Group typically and
they will find a very efficient
logistical scheme to make sure that this
town gets the bread the beans and the
beef and these are typically quite
complicated algorithms so you have a
couple of shipping ports you got to keep
in mind there's a couple of villages you
have to keep in mind there's like
transport costs and that sort of thing
is availability of crops and all that
stuff super interesting problem but they
are very hard these things are like
np-hard people fought fought the
they came up with two letters for it
also like these algorithms typically
don't scale well at all often you need
to have like one single machine because
it's not something you can distribute
easily and it's not unheard of to hear
stories of servers running for like days
and weeks to solve a problem and he's
usually like the algorithms that you
consider they don't even have like a
guarantee of optimality so you're like
Christa feeties initialization cheapest
for this insertion to three opt and
kneeling greedy so if they imagine that
there's like lots and lots of experts
like really clever people trying to sort
of apply all of these things and maybe
get to the optimal solution and stuff
but the thing is the algorithm doesn't
matter because they were solving the
wrong problem because if you hear
someone say I need bread beans and beef
but you should really hear is say I need
carbohydrates fiber and protein
I don't need beans I need nutrients and
you know you might have heard of this
stickler diet problem but if you think
about it the human being needs like a
couple of grams of you know calcium a
few grams of protein calories etc but
you can get them from many different
foodstuffs right and certain foodstuffs
are cheaper than other foodstuffs and
what's more certain foodstuffs are just
closer than others it might be that the
place that has lentils for your town is
a lot closer than the place that has
beans it might be the case that if you
have lentils you only need a truck and
in the cases you have beans you need
some sort of shipyard to get the ship
from a different port now imagine that
you're sort of design trying to design
an algorithm here you can write the best
algorithm ever for this problem but if
you have to find the problem in the
wrong way if not done is one rephrasing
trick you're still solving the wrong
problem and let's be honest here this is
one of those things that the algorithm
will not be able to figure out on its
own you probably want to design an
algorithm to take this sort of stuff
into account because if the algorithm
isn't aware of this search space it
won't be able to look in it and like the
best thing in life of course is that you
can go for something like this for
something like this right and this is
what you're trying to do you're not
trying to write a paper about the
coolest algorithm anything like this but
in this situation you might be saving
lives and that's sort of I think a
cooler thing than optimizing for an ROC
curve
and and I do think there's like this
risk that if you're in a team where only
algorithm people reside it might be very
hard to test the algorithm in the real
world because if you really want to look
at the problem from multiple angles your
team probably needs to be a bit more
into blister-like interdisciplinary in
this particular example and again I
heard about a third hand so I'll just
assume it's mostly true but it wasn't
the algorithm that saved the world
rather he understanding of it a better
algorithm in this case definitely would
have had a worse outcome if it was used
on the wrong problem
and again like taking a step back and
rethinking turns out to be a pretty good
trick turns out though that this is one
of those real-world examples but the
whole taking a step back thing you can
also use that to win in very mechanical
very algorithmic challenges as well so
now I would like to talk about a cago
problem who here does Kegel once in a
while not a whole lot of people I don't
either but there's this one challenge
every year where they have well they
have something with Santa and those are
sort of more the operations research
problems like the the purely
mathematical optimize the system type
problems which is kind of my background
so those are the problems I really
really like and the problem that Kegel
serda came up with is basically he said
you know we Santa forgot how much the
gifts way so I might be able to put a
book in the bag I might be able to put
the ball in the bag and then I have one
bag of gifts maybe we'll put another
book and another two balls in a
different bag but if I put too much
gifts in a bag there's a probability
that the bag my trip and the thing I got
optimizes I want to have as many bags as
possible with with as much weight as
possible but I never want to back to rip
and I don't know exactly how much these
things weigh the only thing I know is
that these things come from a
distribution that carol was nice enough
to supply in this numpy code so horses
wait a certain amount of stuff books
wait a certain amount of stuff blocks
and trains and whatnot and sort of what
you kind of get then is this awkward
moment where you sort of have to
consider am I gonna do like lots of
light bags and then none of the bags
will rip right that's a tactic then I'm
at least very sure that what I send the
Kegel is actually in the score what you
can also do is go for the other out you
can kind of say Oh screw it I'll just
some of the
Bax might be ripped but I'm compensating
because all the other bags will have
lots of stuff in it or you can kind of
make a mix of these two things right but
this is basically the problem when I
send one allocation of all these bags to
Kaggle I get one score back and it's the
total sum of all the non rips bags so I
don't get a whole lot of information
back and you know if your operations
research person the first thing you do
is you write stuff like this down so
what are you optimizing and what is sort
of the constraint so the weight I was
sort of thinking about the problem was
you just have to sort of assign an item
to a bag and then you can sort of take
the expected value of the item as sort
of the thing you gain but you have to do
this with the constraint because you do
want to minimize the risk that you're
going to get near the max weight and I
thought I did pretty cool with them
there's a colleague of mine yells I was
doing this we had a really great time as
a fun puzzle so I used all our tools
with some simulated weights and I
generated lots of solutions and I sort
of had a tactic above like upload often
and pray not the best tactic I can say
we had a lot of fun so it's fun and
other people they also did sort of the
the guessing game so they would like
upload three times a day really try to
sort of learn the weight of this one
little gift and then sort of the game
became that a lot of people were sort of
calculating how many uploads they needed
in order to perfectly solve the problem
so say and the forum was great you just
read whatever people were doing there
was lots of hackings and stuff but a lot
of the problems were sort of around this
solution as well so that was content and
then after a few weeks as someone on the
forum demonstrated that everyone was
solving the wrong problem and let's
focus on an epic hint the Kaggle gave us
this is how everything was generated
right so presumably one part of the coda
they did not show was this
all right so I'm about to read a part of
the coggle forum for you and this was
actually on the Congo form so this was
someone the guy named the guy's name was
Toby cheese and if you're out there on
YouTube again this was one of the things
that you know made my day so what he
read what he said was there was one
thing left in this competition that I
wanted to do ever since a discussion
started and that thing was to see if
maybe it's possible to brute force the
seed values used to generate the toy
weights imagine my disappointment when I
actually succeeded and then there's some
extra information apparently the the
number of possible seeds is only like
somewhere in the like four billion area
instead of like multiples of ten higher
than that because of some weird numpy
internals the wolf I need to maybe talk
to you about that I'm interested to know
hear your story and also this is seating
so like you can paralyze this on many
different computers which is what the
guy did essentially he like this giant
for loop and totally paralyzed that and
all sorts of cores and the thing was he
submitted one score and if any one of
his sort of random seeds sort of met
that one allocation perfectly bang
you've got your hit and all your risk is
gone here's the official statement from
Kaggle so the cackle team said yes I'm
embarrassed to admit that in my pre
holiday scramble to put this together
I thought about extra seeds to bury it
but I didn't do it well enough so we had
like two random seed points it wasn't
enough so there was still enough
information that Toby was able to learn
and this is this was like one of those
marvelous moments where you're just
thinking I get that it's like really
hard to think outside of the box when
you're in it and that's also sort of why
this like hilarious awesome optimal
solution okay goal is almost an
afterthought but this will happen in
real life for us as well it's not just a
real-world problem this is probably
gonna be the algorithmic problems as
well and I kind of have a like this
personal theory that I got from John
Cleese but like I do think maybe a way
to deal with this is like it does show
that good ideas pop around when you're
not in like work work mode it's a lot
better to sort of try to get these ideas
when you're sort of more in a work
played five minutes got you so I think
encouraging this work play mode thing is
kind of like a no-brainer if you're an
organization you've got a bunch of smart
creative people just give them some
playtime once in a while
because I think that's the only way that
you're able to get sort of hacks like
this in your team and it might just be
super beneficial to your business and
the next story will demonstrate this
point even more and I will say with this
story it is
I think hilarious but it's very hard to
verify if it's true I read in the book
it's true but the books from the 80s but
as a story goes right it's about a time
series problem but as the story goes
there is a condom Factory and they kind
of have this problem because the thing
is when you make your product either the
factory has to be on then you make lots
of the thing and then you have to move
it to the warehouse but both the factory
and the warehouse are like super
expensive and they're really hard to
turn on and off because you hire the
factory in a lot of cases so then what
you got to do is you got a sort of plan
when the factory can be on or off
because the competitor might be using
the factory at the same time so you can
have to be able to plan this around if
you will so then a clever guy supposedly
came up with a business case and the
idea was as follows it was like the 90s
80s I suppose right so yeah this like
small army of consultants and suits
let's call them the Econometrica army
and the business case a sort of goth was
they basically said look if you can
predict a demand for this product then
we were much able to plan the factory
and then also we're much better much
better to plan like the warehouse and
it's like going to be a huge huge cost
saver like this this will be great so
the Econometrica army supposedly in a
story they they went in they fiddled
around I have two months but they came
back and said yep it's really hard to
predict no dice so management is like
super disappointed and then you know as
a story would go like one of the
managers is having a walk in the park
and it sort of occurred to the manager
person because if you think about it the
problem sort of is that we want to
predict this time series p1 but it turns
out that p1 is impossible to predict and
apparently because it's hard to predict
that's the thing that makes planning the
the factory kind of hard so how about we
ignore the time series but we do
something it makes the planning of the
factory super easy because what you
could also do then is you can sort of
say you know what how about I just find
a different product made from the same
material that correlates negatively
if there is such a product where if you
know product one is super high product
two is super low and vice versa then
there's no need to predict the market
because you're always able to produce
something supposedly this is how latex
pacifiers got invented I don't know if
this is true but I do like the story and
I like the story so much because when I
read the story for the first time I
really took me by surprise like I'm an
algorithmic person I'm trained with the
idea that my algorithm thing is the
thing that solves the other thing but
this is one of those examples where it's
sort of obvious that the only way you're
gonna get the solution is if you allow
yourself a bit more creativity if you're
a liar or sell to sort of think out the
box and maybe as you know if we want the
AR winner to sort of never happen if you
want to sort of convince people in suits
that machine learning is great maybe we
also need to get better at understanding
the theater and like recommending next
episode and considering lentils over
beans and pivoting the pacifiers and
that sort of thing because the more and
more I started thinking about it and
some of the crazy stuff that I hear from
like my peers like I really
fundamentally think that understanding
the problem it's much more important
than the selling the solution and just
in general I think we should maybe take
a step back and think more about the
system around the algorithm and when
you're designing a system it's probably
a much better idea than a focus on a
single part but rather maybe the
communication between two parts like
having a bit more of a holistic view
there might be like a really good thing
and especially in this case like it's
kind of sin but rephrasing might be your
best friend it's like take a lot someone
was routine reflect on what you're doing
maybe you've rephrase the problem in the
wrong way and when you're doing that
you're probably gonna realize that maybe
need to stop being just a data team and
maybe just need to be more of an
interdisciplinary team that owns a part
of the like the product or just a
product team or something like that
don't live in a rabbit hole should
really try to prevent this intellectual
laziness it's really okay they have to
admit that you might not really fully
understand the problem and it's
definitely okay also for burnout reasons
to take a break once in a while and a
lot of these problems I really think
they solve themselves if you go running
or you just have like one of your banter
moments like only Dutch people will get
that reference but if you just have one
of those banter moments with your
friends in the bar and I guess the only
thing I have to say after this is like
go to your
local theater because there's amazing
stuff to see on stage Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]